Hi everyone. I'm Kathy Chen and I am
a product manager here in Cambridge.
Um,
I just wanted to kind of express how
excited I am to bring Debbie here to
Cambridge to talk to all of us.
I'm actually a Grad Student at Columbia
University full time in a master's
degree program in something
called organizational psychology.
And one of the things that we cover
there is a leadership and a lot of things
around gender,
also negotiations.
So I've had the privilege of having
a Debbie as a lecturer for my, uh,
for my course.
And so my class actually ranges
from people who are politicians,
uh,
like there's a mayor of a small town in
Connecticut all the way through like a
chief of staff to a senator.
And then there's other people who
are like chief of it for a hospital,
that kind of thing. And even then in that
class, like a very experienced people,
everybody learns something
about negotiations when
Debbie was there. So, uh,
another day during class,
Debbie Ashley talked a little bit more
about diversity and leadership training.
And so I'm really pleased to have her
here. To talk a little bit about both. Um,
Debbie is a Deloitte Ellen
Gabriel professor for women
in leadership and Marita.
She doesn't look retired,
but she is and a distinguished research
fellow at the center for Gender in
organizations at Simmons
schools management.
And for those of you who don't
know much about Simmons, but the,
the center is actually funded by the
Ford Foundation from 1991 and 94.
Debbie was executive director of the
program on negotiation at Harvard law
school and she currently is a senior
fellow of the PR of that program where she
co-directs the negotiations
at the workplace project.
She's also an adjunct professor at NC,
at business school in Fontainebleau,
France.
Debbie runs women's executive leadership
programs for places like Time Warner
and Deloitte and Deutscha bank and using
what she's observed about executives
there and these leadership programs.
Debbie is integrated those
stories into this book.
So the book is based on
women's real life examples.
She's also written many books and articles
about conflict and mediation and is
an authority on negotiation.
So today she's here to talk about her
fourth book on negotiations and gender.
And if you want more information about
those other books that she's written,
you can find her bio and the website
link on, go negotiating at work.
There's also a dory there if you have
questions and she's gonna talk for about
half an hour and then take questions
at the end. So with no further ado,
here's Debbie.
Cool.
Thank you. Kathy. Can you
hear me? God, this is hard.
The lightest right in my
eyes. Um, so let me, I'm,
I'm delighted actually to be here in
preparation. Read the book about Google,
um,
by your former CEO and Jonathan Rosenberg.
And I can tell you in negotiation is an
important part of work there. It seemed,
it seemed to me.
So let me just place this book in context
before I sort of talk about some of
the principles of negotiation
that are in the book.
So I've written a lot of books about
negotiation on the one that was most, uh,
well known was something called the
shadow in negotiation. And in that book,
what I did was I looked at, you
know, we know about getting to, yes,
I'm about the principles of mutual gains,
negotiation in the shadow negotiation.
And I talked about the
relationship building
relationships and how you advocate
for yourself and connect with others.
And so that book has done quite well.
They came out in paperback in
it with a different title. Um,
but through my leadership
development activities,
both leadership programs for
women but also more generally.
So Kathy's program is obviously
a mixed a mixed group.
I really started to see how experienced
leaders manage some of the challenges of
internal and negotiation. And the actual
motivation for this book came from,
I teach a PR, I run a
program in Chicago, um,
that brings people from different
companies for our several module program.
I'm the academic advisor
and I teach in it.
And at the end of one of these programs,
when you know,
you're saying goodbye to everybody
and everybody's hugging and kissing,
this woman came up to me and she said,
the negotiation module
changed my life thinking, wow,
that's really pretty terrific.
There must be a story here.
And so she told me her story.
And from that understood from that sort
of her sending me in setting this idea
in motion about stories,
I started to collect stories
from experienced practitioners.
So this is a book about stories,
Mex experienced practitioners.
I've done a lot of work on this
topic before I've interviewed,
but this is a different
book because it's got these,
it's got these stories in
it from practitioners. So
let me ask you a question.
Um,
how many of you would describe yourself?
So this is a question I always ask at the
beginning of a leadership program that
I teach in negotiation.
I asked the question,
how many of you would describe yourself
as successful in dealing with clients,
customers, suppliers, places
where you are acting as an agent,
either for your group or for Google.
How many of you would describe
yourself as successful in that? Okay.
And then I can ask,
I have no way of verifying this.
What makes you successful? So
what makes you successful? Yeah.
Yeah.
So being positioned to his competition
recently or your goals and what makes you
get into a position to accomplish that.
Okay, so you build relationships
with people externally.
What else makes you successful? What?
What makes you when you act as an agent?
Yeah,
you're nice.
What does that mean? Nice.
You're collaborative,
you're willing to make concessions.
What does nice mean
to,
okay, so you're a good listener, right?
You're trying to find some kind of
agreement that both of you are happy with.
So that means nice.
What else makes you successful?
Yeah.
Right?
So knowing the right people being
very well, people always say,
I'm very well prepared. I know the right
people. I know what they're likely to do.
I'm very well prepared under
those circumstances. I listened.
I look for mutual gains
agreements, I think, I assume
that's what's behind. Nice.
Um,
and so then I asked the question
that's negotiating as an agent,
what I call this capital
letter and negotiation. And
then I asked the question,
what's different when you're
negotiating for yourself?
You're not an agent.
You're what we call a principal.
So what's different when you negotiate
for yourself? What's different?
Nothing.
It's the same,
sorry,
not so clear. How you can discover
what's mutually beneficial.
It might depend on the situation.
What else is different?
Yeah.
People reacted differently when they see
someone asking for something on behalf
of mothers versus for themselves.
Right?
Of course. What did they see? So w so what
do they see and then what do you feel?
Even if you don't feel it, it's easy
to feel like, oh, I shouldn't be asking
people just to see it.
They serve,
they see and so they see it differently
and you sort of incorporate that a
little bit. You can feel a little bit
greedy asking. Right. And so could make,
it might make negotiation a little
bit more emotional. What else?
Bothering people. It's just sort of
much harder in negotiating with this,
what I call this sort of lower
case in negotiations. You know,
it's hard to get negotiations started.
We don't have a structure for doing it.
It's often hard to figure out what
you want in this context. You know,
if you're in, when you're a
capital letter and negotiation,
it's pretty clear about what you're
going after. You might change your ideas,
but when you're negotiating for yourself,
sometimes it's hard to do that.
It might be hard to stay
in the negotiation. Yeah.
When you say lower case n negotiation,
the parties being individuals,
are you referring to where one of them
is an individual or the other one is
actually an organization?
I'm actually thinking about your,
you could be negotiating a,
what's an of you is an little
end negotiation negotiating
with an organization.
Well for example,
negotiating a salary
with your superior as an individual.
You're negotiating with them
as representative of the Lord.
But that's, but the is it?
But it manifests itself as
an individual negotiation.
Right.
The position I take is
they are representing the
total organization and when
they respond to what you asked for,
that's what they're representing.
But it actually is two individuals
actually sitting down and negotiating.
Is that right?
How would that be?
Any different from an upper gives
a negotiation breaks dope too.
Well, cause I I that's what I'm
asking you. It's a difference.
I would think so because,
because in New York in the first
situation it capital end negotiation,
you are a representative, right?
Negotiating with a representative, right?
And lowercase n negotiation,
you're negotiating on behalf of
yourself as an individual and you might
negotiate with somebody who
is representing something
else, but you're the agent.
And so is it different? Right. And also,
I guess what I'm trying to ask is that
are you distinguishing the two cases
where you as an individual and negotiating
with an organization versus you as an
individual? I haven't. I'm,
I'm distinguishing when you are
negotiating on behalf of yourself,
that's the key. I don't care who
you're negotiating with, God,
it could actually be, you know, buying a
car. It could be a little end negotiation.
You negotiate it with a car dealership,
but you want the best price and it's you,
right? Unless you're negotiating on
behalf of your parents, your children,
your spouse or somebody,
you're negotiating as a principal.
So the thing that's important to me
is who you are in those negotiations.
We'll also talk about who the other
person or the person is as well.
So let me ask you some questions about
what kinds of little end negotiations do
you have at Google.
What do you negotiate about when you're
negotiating for yourself at Google?
What kinds do you have? Who gets assigned
to bug? Who gets assigned to a bug?
Okay, so work, right? What else?
And you have a preference
about that or not, right?
What'd you say? You don't
want to get it right. Okay.
What else do you negotiate about
little end negotiations at Google?
Yeah, involvement or growth
opportunities. Career Development,
growth opportunities.
Those are negotiations.
You're trying to get sort
of things that you can do.
That's a little end negotiation. It's
you're negotiating on behalf of yourself.
What else do you negotiate for a desk?
A desk to sit.
Okay.
I didn't really think about that,
but I guess that that would be true
and that's where to sit. What else?
Also a flexible work arrangement.
Sex that will work.
Arrangements can be and can be that as
well. So I think as we go through this,
it would be useful for you.
Have in your mind a little end negotiation
that you might be struggling with so
that as we talk about it,
you might be able to think about it.
So what I want to do is add gender to
our story of little end negotiations.
And I want to say a few things, you
know, so we have a class here, you know,
gender is not just about women.
Uh, it's an I and I'm not,
when I talk about gender,
I'm not talking about the
differences between men and women.
I'm talking about what we call second
generation gender issues that his policies
and practices and culture that on its
face looks natural and neutral but can
have differential impacts on men and women
and different groups of men and women.
And I always like to say when we
talk about women in these issues,
I always like to say it's like the Canary
in the mine that we sort of understand
some of the issues that might
be effecting a minority group,
which is true in a Google might have
implications for the majority group as
well.
So one of the ways we like to talk about
what it means to have to talk about
second generation gender issues is
to use the example of the US Capitol.
So the US capital was built in the 18
hundreds and of course when they built it,
they had no ladies rooms because
they had no ladies. Right.
And in 1917 the first woman was elected
to the US House of Representatives.
And in 1932 the first two,
the Senate prior to 1962 con Congress
women shared a single bathroom far from
the chamber even though there were many
in the house in 1992 the women senators
were given restrooms on the same floor
as the Senate Chamber Chamber in 2011
forestall bathrooms were put in the house.
And in 2013 they actually put women's
restrooms in the Senate and near the
Chamber when there were 20 women senators.
And so the idea is that nobody was
doing this explicitly to discriminate.
It just was, there were no women.
And so they weren't room for,
there wasn't need for women's restrooms.
And that sort of the idea about
second generation gender issues,
that is they are,
um,
they come into existence because they fit
the lives and the work style a certain
majority group. And we don't sort
of think about how it works, um, uh,
for people that aren't in that majority.
So I want to give you some examples
about we're negotiation comes in there.
The first is people are offered
jobs that they don't want to take,
like fix the bug, right? And
you're expected to say yes.
And so what are some of those?
Well,
in financial service organization is
often the case that women get assigned
managerial operational jobs that
is run the office, run the country.
And there's not a lot of value to that.
It's obviously the value isn't
sales in financial services or in a,
in a,
a major manufacturing company I know of
women get channeled into human resource
roles because the idea, the belief
is, or they're an operations,
which is really the privilege place,
they won't be able to manage it because
of work and family issues or in, uh,
in professional services firms, women
often get put in a chief of staff roles,
right?
And the key thing there is you're asked
to do something you might not want to do
it.
And so the key is how you negotiate to
make it fit with what you want to do.
The second is we have outdated
job criteria so that, um, uh,
often, uh, people aren't on the screen.
So somebody mentioned
negotiating for opportunities
and that's one of the things,
um, there, so in one organization,
people, people say we have higher,
like me,
at a certain level in an organization,
people don't know exactly what
they're looking for in leadership.
So the best thing is let's let me find
someone who looks just like me, right?
And so if you don't fit that,
if you don't look just like that,
it's up to you to negotiate for that
opportunity. I do a lot of work in Africa.
Um, and a story about this
woman lived in rural Nairobi.
She's a phd scientist and all of the work
with the important work was in Nairobi.
But nobody ever offered her an opportunity
because they assumed she wouldn't
move,
that she wouldn't leave her family that
was in rural rural Kenya or another
woman who was picked up work that when
her boss left and was actually doing the
work of a vice president,
and she did it for three months,
but nobody thought to offer her the
actual role. So she had to negotiate it.
Women often get asked to
do more invisible work.
It was just a column in the New York
Times by Sheryl Sandburg and Adam Grant
about women housework at work asked,
being asked to do things like
mentor other people. You know,
I think this happens for people who are
different as well. Diversity Mentor,
other people run a run
a, uh, group, um, uh,
beyond the diversity committee.
All those kinds of things that are extra
work and their presumed that you will
do it.
It's invisible work.
And so part of the challenge
there is to negotiate value.
And one of the things that we know is
that when people do invisible work and
actually has a benefit for organizations,
um,
and so we have to claim value for that
integrating work and family. Right?
So somebody said flexible
work arrangements.
Well it isn't just flexible
work arrangements. It sort of,
we have this vision of
the ideal worker and boy,
the ideal worker at
Google is alive and well.
I think you're supposed to be
there all the time. Right? Um, the,
the heroic stories in this book,
we're about people who
worked long weekends and long
nights to do all the work.
So if you have family responsibilities,
that becomes sort of an issue in the
way is how do you negotiate to make that
work? One of my favorite stories is
about this woman who was in procurement,
in oil and gas. And to get
promoted, you had to relocate.
And this situation to Ghana,
and she had a family,
she didn't want to live
in Ghana for three years,
but what she was able to negotiate was
sort of a commuting relationship so that
she was in Indiana for
a few weeks at a time.
And then we'd come back
to Dallas and go back.
So negotiating to make work arrangement
work in the face of expectations about
the ideal worker. And the final
thing is about mandate for change.
So by there's this research, uh,
that's about the glass cliff.
And here's the story.
The story is that when
organizations are not doing well,
the likelihood that a woman is going to
be put in a senior leadership role goes
up, right? Think Melissa Mayer.
Think Mary Barra at General Motors.
Think Meg Whitman at Hewlett Packard.
And so the glass cliff means that
you're put in charge of these risky
enterprises. And I guess the reason it's
called a glass cliff is if you succeed,
great. If not, you're off the cliff.
But the idea is when you take on
one of these risky, uh, risky roles,
you need to negotiate for
support so that you're a,
so if it doesn't do all that well,
you're a, you're sort of protected.
So when I want to do is
talk about three challenges,
I've sort of spent a lot of
time talking about the context.
Someone talking about three things,
getting negotiations off the
ground because the structure
doesn't look the same
in little end negotiations,
get their situation that is really
trying to understand where they're coming
from and dealing with resistance,
their resistance to change.
So getting no growth. Here's the,
here's the challenge. Excuse me,
I'm here to talk about sources of my
project. Yeah. Later. Uh, so negotiations,
little end negotiations don't
have a structure, right?
You have to construct
them out of whole cloth.
So what are some of the ways you'd
get negotiations off the ground?
There are two major ways that
we write about in the book.
There are others as well. The first
one is to make your value visible.
People negotiate with you because you
have something they want and you need to
make it visible in what we call
a currency that matters to them.
So it isn't just that you work hard.
It's what they think about
that matters to them.
That makes a difference because
you're trying to build in some kind of
reciprocity that is,
you're trying to get them to the table.
So let me tell you a story.
This is about a woman.
She was a director of external
relations at a very large man,
Midwest manufacturing company.
And she was asked by people in
another division. They were, uh,
they were the legislative division to
help save a really important client that
they had at the state level.
Um,
they were about to lose the client
and it was going to be a very big, um,
it was going to be, this is a
company that supplies, um, uh, uh,
resources, you know, uh,
all kinds of equipment and stuff to
come to companies and businesses and
buildings, a stuffer
buildings. And so she did it.
She helped,
she saved this client.
She got huge amount of Kudos
presented to the board, the CEO,
it was terrific. But then they
kept asking her to keep doing it.
They would call her up and they would say,
we need your help again in another state.
And you know,
she really liked to
help so she would help.
But she found that she was spending a lot
of time doing this work and it was not
her job.
So the first thing that she did is she
goes to her boss and she tries to make
her value visible in a
currency that matters to him.
So she talks about how
she cost her contribution,
how much time she's
spending and what it costs.
And then she talks about what she's the,
how she's really saved the client,
what a benefit it has been.
So she makes her value visible in what
she thinks is a currency that has value.
And he says it's terrific,
but the time isn't right.
You need to be patient.
So the second,
so that's making your value
of it didn't actually work.
So the second is using your leverage and
what do we mean by your leverage? Well,
there's a concept in negotiation.
Probably many of you know it. I mean,
I think of a lot of, you've taken
negotiation courses here at Google.
The concept of Batna.
Everybody know Batna. Yeah.
You know your best alternative to a
negotiated agreement. You asked herself,
what happens if I can't reach agreement
here? What am I going to be forced to do?
What are they going to be forced to do?
So in her situation,
her Batna,
I is what?
What's our alternative?
If she can't get her boss to negotiate
what's her Bandana is actually to stop
doing the work for this other group.
But she does it in a way that we
call smoothing out your Batna.
So it isn't so abrupt or so threatening.
Maybe.
So the first thing that she
does is she uses question.
She goes to this other group. The next
time they ask her and she says, you know,
this is really taking too much of my time.
I'm really concerned.
How will you handle this
if I don't do it right?
So she's letting them know
about her alternative,
but she's doing it in a way that's
very engaging. And so they say, well,
there is somebody that's
supposed to be handling,
but that person doesn't
do a very good job,
so I don't think it would really
work for us. We really do need you.
Then she says to them, let's focus
on the purpose. I always like to say,
you want to connect what's good for you
to what's good for the organization.
And so she talked to them about why it
would be good for her to have this work
as part of her job. And they
say, right, it would be.
And so they become her ally and
they go to her boss and they say,
we really need, this woman's name was
Isabelle. We need Isabelle to do this.
And that gets her boss to the table.
So she gets him to the table,
they reorganize her job.
She now has the legislative
part of part of her work.
And the key thing was is that she used
her alternative with somebody else who
could act as an ally for her.
So I'm interested,
do you have problems getting people to
the table and what kinds of things have
you used?
What are some of the things you've used
to get people to the table to negotiate
with you? So yes, in a salary negotiation,
I used an offer from another company,
right? So you know there's a really
interesting way to do that. I call it,
we call him the Bobi called
smoothing out your Batna.
So one things you can say is,
I have this other offer, right?
But the other thing you can say is this
is that's just letting you know your
Batna, smoothing out your Batna.
Say I had this other offer,
but I'd much rather stay at Google. Right?
So you let them know about your Batna,
but you do it in a very
engaging kind of way.
And I think this idea about smoothing
out your Batna is a really nice,
a nice concept.
It lets people know you have alternatives,
but you do it in a way that I think is
consistent with a collaborative culture
at Google.
Any other things that people have used
to get people to the table with them?
Nothing else. No other hints. Okay.
Well hopefully it was just
some of these. Nope. Okay.
So let me go to the next
point that I want to make,
which is the idea about getting
who they are and what they want.
So we had this sense
that I'm in negotiation,
we want to focus on people's interest,
you know,
to come up with mutual gains agreements.
But you know,
that there's more behind what people
want than just the issues that are on the
table.
People look at the person
you're negotiating with
considers him or herself in
the context of the larger organization.
So for example,
if you're negotiating salary,
if somebody is going to give
you a salary that you want,
they want to think about
what's the implication of
this to other people, right?
So this notion of how they
think about their, uh,
themselves in relation to,
uh, to the things that they
might, they might give you.
And so I usually like to put this slide
up because one of the things we think
about is we tend to see ourselves as
the heroes and heroines of our stories.
So we like to say we're strategic.
We take the long term perspective,
we see the big picture. We act in
the organization's best interest.
We're flexible and collaborative.
They on the other hand are opportunistic.
They're short term thinkers. They have
narrow vision. They're out for themselves,
rigid, an uncooperative. And I have to
tell you, nobody wakes up in the morning,
looks at him or herself in the
mirror and says, I'm opportunistic.
I'm a short term thinker, I have narrow
vision, I'm out for myself. Average.
Everybody thinks they're
operating on that left hand side.
That what they're doing and responding
to you is legitimate and strategic in
their view.
So what I'd like to say is when you think
about getting their perspective is to
think about there good
reasons for saying no to you.
Good reasons on that left hand side.
What would their good
reasons for saying no to you?
Because that's the hidden agenda of
any of these negotiations, right?
It's their reasons for saying no.
So let me tell you this story about,
this was the story actually the woman I
told you about right in the beginning.
So, um, she's the vice president,
chief financial officer of a
division of an energy company.
And the condition of taking this job was
that she moved to Texas and she moved
to Texas.
And uh,
she was there for two years and her
family said at the end of two years,
we're going back to Pennsylvania,
which is where they were from,
with or without you. And that's when
she said to me, the negotiation changed.
My, changed my life because what
she recognized, first of all,
it was that she had leverage and her
leverage was that the chief financial
officer of the company relied on her to
have a relationship with people in the
field. So that made her feel
like she had value to negotiate.
The second thing that she did,
and I think this is really important,
when you raise an issue in
a little end negotiation,
chances are you're raising a problem
and when you raise a problem,
you're the problem.
And so it really makes sense
to come in with good options.
We call it in the book anchor with options
because if you anchor with options,
you come in at a frames the negotiation.
So let me tell you what this woman did.
Her name is Cheryl.
So Charlotte negotiated with the chief
financial officer and she came up with
this idea of something
she called the Tri Office,
which was sometime in
corporate headquarters,
sometime in the field and
sometime in Pennsylvania.
But then she thought about what are his
good reasons for saying no. By the way,
when we tell people about negotiation,
where we say prepare, prepare, prepare,
and when you prepare, prepare, prepare,
you often can't hear what
the good reasons are.
So it's really important to leave it,
I call it, we call it being mindful.
So when she thought about his
good reasons, first she was,
she thought he might think she
wouldn't be able to do the job right.
She wouldn't be able to in in this
kind of as if she wasn't corporate
headquarters,
she wouldn't really be able to do the job.
So she built into her
offer performance criteria.
They would look at performance criteria.
The second thing is she thought
he might think it was too costly.
He paid for a move already and
he might not want to do it again.
So she built in a cluster,
Sharon provision.
The third thing was he was afraid if she
left, he loses connection to the field.
So they built in a way that
she could deal with the field.
He thought that she would be tired,
get tired of the commute.
So they had periodic check ins.
And the final thing was he
wouldn't want to change precedent.
There's nothing she could do about that.
But what she did was thinking about
his good reasons for saying no.
And in the negotiations, I
always like to say, you know,
if you know a good reason that
people are going to say no,
it's great to start there. So
she could say, and you know,
I think you worried about my performance
that this is going to jeopardize that.
And he said, right. And once
they're able to talk about it,
it sort of can lower the resistance
a little bit. It's a nice story.
They did a pilot, it worked. And Child,
she's vice president and
general of that division.
So the final thing I want to talk about
is what we call dealing with resistance.
That is you, you, um, uh, you
raise something. So here it is,
uh, you put out an idea, the person that
says this will never work. You say, yes,
it will. And he says you're wrong.
And she says, no, no, I'm right.
And what happens in these kinds of
things? I talk about this as, um,
moves and countermoves. So when people
don't want to give you what you want,
they say things that can put you on
the defensive. They're resistance.
And so they defend, they question your
competence. They say, this budget, sweat,
align. Uh, everybody else
can do this. Why can't you?
Or they criticize your style. You're
being unreasonable or don't get so upset.
They demean your ideas,
which were ever get these numbers from.
This will never work. Or they appeal
for sympathy. This is really the killer.
I think I really need your help on this.
I'm very stretched.
So please just hold.
That's what the boss did and Isabelle's
case or they flatter you. Another killer.
You're so good at this. Why wouldn't
you want to keep doing it all?
80 hours of it.
And so what happens is we get into
this move and counter move like this as
opposed to thinking about what we call
turns and turns changed the dynamics.
So the first term you can
always use is interruption
silenced. It's very heavy,
right? You take a break,
you interrupt because you never
come back to exactly the same place.
Or you can ask a question, you can correct
it or you couldn't solve a problem.
So I want to give you an example.
This is a story about a woman.
This is again from Africa,
she is on a phd,
economist works for Large Ngo.
The coin of the realm is doing research,
but also having your work make
a difference on the ground.
So her name is Rosa Lee
and she's coming to talk.
You can tell this organization to
the assistant director general.
Did you get a sense of
what this organization must
be like with an assistant
director general?
And she comes and she says,
I've come to talk to you
about funding to present it.
The next international congress.
I just published an important article
in the Journal of Agricultural Economics
and I want to present it. And he says,
I'm not familiar with that journal.
But as you know, we need senior people
to come and present at these conferences.
That's where we meet with donors
and you're not ready. And she says,
I can't believe you're saying that
I am ready to present. And he says,
look, I really need you
to support the work here.
You are best at helping me in the director
general get ready to the conference.
And she says, no way am I just
going to help you present my data.
I need to be there too. And
he says, don't get so upset.
And she says, I am not upset. Right.
So that's an example of resistance,
counter resistance.
So let's look at it from
a perspective of turns.
So she says the same thing.
He says the same thing,
but instead of responding
in a countermove, she says,
she asks a question,
help me understand the criteria used
to determine whether people are ready.
Right? So she opens it up
and he says, we need it.
And so he said pretty much the same thing,
but she hears it differently, right?
He gives, she asked a
question, he gives a reason
then knowing that she can correct it.
I understand what a priority this project
is and I want to support you and the
director general so you can
meet with donors and he says,
I'm glad you understand. Okay, so
now she's getting cooled out here.
That doesn't work. So she says she
jumps to the problem and she said,
since I am most familiar with the data,
I think the best way to support the
project is for me to do the presentations
and be available to answer questions that
donors have that would help the donors
have confidence in our junior researchers.
Right?
So she expands the product from just
herself to something that's good for the
organization.
It's good for junior resources and for
donors to know that junior resources that
researchers are doing important work.
And so he says,
actually I think that would work.
I'm going to run it by the DJ. Now,
obviously this is a very
stylized kind of situation,
but the idea about being prepared when
people are going to use these moves that
put you on the defensive.
And what I would like to say in the book,
which we didn't,
I didn't talk about today's knowing
what you know about the person you're
dealing with.
What do they do in these kinds of
negotiations so you can be prepared.
So the final thing I just say is,
you know, this book, um, we, the,
the subtitle of the book is called,
uh, turning small wins into big gains.
And our notion about this is that these
kinds of negotiations over these issues
actually make some change.
So if you think of that Isabel
that was doing this extra work,
she becomes a role model for changing
the idea that invisible work and just
helping has no cost.
It has a cost and it should
be built in to a job. Cheryl,
in this tri office actually
changes a precedent.
It is no longer the case that it is
expected that people will move to the
corporate office as a condition of
taking on a very senior leadership job.
They might, but it's non
negotiable. It's not just assumed.
And Rosalee changes the role
of the junior researchers.
Now the leadership of the organization
is open to the idea that junior research,
it's actually a good thing for
junior researchers to present.
So negotiation becomes a way to
change kind of cultural practices.
So I think it's not just good for you.
I think it can be good
for the organization.
So we have some time for questions.
People have questions.
Zone is from Beca.
I'd love tips on helping him manager
understand the value of work that is done
outside of one's core
role, right? For example,
training or mentoring others.
It's important for the greater
good of Google or for your work,
but can be hard to defend in the
face of an ambitious team goal.
Right.
So I mean again,
I think the most important thing there
is how do you connect, why it's good,
what are the benefits?
You'd have to be able to quantify
those benefits in some way. You know,
sometimes people say, you know, when we
mentor people it means that they stay,
you know,
I reading this book about Google losing
talent is something that Google isn't so
happy about. So the idea if
you're mentoring people to stay,
especially if they're in a minority group,
the idea that you're helping
them stay would be uh,
putting this in a currency that has
value presumably to the person you're
dealing with. Other people have
suggestions for how you do that as well.
I don't think I have to be the only one
answering that question. How do you,
how do you make invisible work that you
do that isn't just generically value
cause it doesn't contribute
directly to the work you're doing?
How do you claim value for it?
Anybody have any other ideas?
Have you done it?
Yeah,
build it into your goals.
Right?
Okay. Yeah, I mean I think the idea
there is to connect what's good.
I always like to say
there are a few stuff,
a few principles that I have here that
I had in my notes, but I didn't say it.
And one of them is connecting what's
good for you to what's good for the
organization.
You need to be able to talk about why
it's good and the degree to which you can
do that. I think, uh, sort
of, uh, it makes a difference.
Okay.
So the question was the
answer was in reviews,
bring it up and have it built into your
goals. That's a good time. You know,
and I say negotiation doesn't present
itself as sort of clear opportunities,
but reviews are often, um,
uh, a place to do that.
And in the book we talk about,
we have a lot of examples about how
you build in these kinds of things to
ongoing conversations, like
reviews, like project reviews,
how you stop that conversation and
build something else in that you want to
accomplish.
Yes.
So you started by talking about framing
your value in a way that matters to the
other party. But, um,
in my experience as a young professional
in when I was negotiating for my first
job, my pre, prior to this one,
I had no idea what my value was.
They had grades and I had no idea how to
explain that grades would be useful and
I got a job. So somehow it,
but they thought I had value,
but it was never clear to me what they
saw or how I could highlight that.
Right,
right.
But you know,
when you're getting
hired right out of school,
you don't have value on a currency that
has value yet they have to determine
what it is.
But over time and working,
you do have value and a
currency that has value. I mean,
I think the hiring is sort of different,
right? I mean, I think, you know,
Google looks for talent and good grades,
right?
So you probably had somebody thought
you had talent and you probably had good
grades and they thought, okay, I mean
when I gathered from reading about Google,
the interviewing process is a really
important part. But I think over time,
little end, that's not a little end
negotiation. Actually. That's more,
you're negotiating for it to get hired.
It's a little bit,
it is a little end in some ways,
but it's not in terms of the ongoing work.
So now you do have a value and want
to change things where you want
opportunities. That's
when you really, I think,
have to show your value to
persistent question is how
do you know your own value?
Especially as a younger professional.
If you don't know your value,
they won't know it either.
Right?
And so you also talk to people you need
to, you know. So one of the things is,
you know, we always think we're
on our own and doing this,
you not to talk to other
people in your network.
Help them get some advice from
people who've done it before.
How did they see their value? What are
the kinds of things that matter? You know,
I,
one of the things in the book that we
talk about is knowing what you know about
the person you're dealing with.
How do they like to hear things?
What do they value?
So finding information about the person
you're gonna negotiate can also help you
help you do that, but you're
not on your own. Exactly.
Do you have a comment about that?
So I actually sit on our new
Grad hiring committee, so I see,
so you just go by a lot.
I tend to not to see what the offers are,
but I do see the candidates go by.
Um,
and as far as knowing what your
value is and that situation, um,
shop yourself around, right? It's,
it's like often when I want to know the
value of an old piece of electronics,
I go to Ebay and see what people are
paying for it. Shop yourself around,
see what Twitter will offer you.
See what Facebook will
after you see what you know,
any other company out there we'll offer
you and then come back to, to Google.
Because you know,
you wanted to work at Google even though
you're interviewing all these other
places, but come back to them and say,
well, these guys were gonna offer me this.
I have a competing offer.
Nothing gets the recruiters into action
faster than having competing offers.
And I think you'll find that true
throughout your professional career,
no matter what level you are
a applying to be hired into
heading another offer is a bat na,
there were such suggests you need to do
a little bit careful about how you use
that directly.
One of the things that I like to
say is when you have another offer,
you know your value and so therefore
what you're asking for fields defensible,
you can stand behind it. Some of the
research suggests, especially with women,
when you drag out that other offer,
people don't hear it so well.
I think you're an experienced
person on the hiring committee.
Other people might sort of not do it,
but I definitely want to,
I am not involved directly in negotiating.
Right.
Just so I was looking did they look good?
Right, right. It's just going to say
in terms of like knowing your worth,
like talk to your peers, talk.
Exactly. Peer reviews. Um, you know,
when we have yearly Perf,
I think that's a great place and just
just get real time feedback. Right.
You don't have to wait, like to go, just
don't go. And I'll get an offer. Right,
right. Yeah. Hr. Um, but, you know, I
think that it's, it's more than just your,
you know, there is a lot of other
ways than just going out to,
to see what Facebook would pay you.
Great.
Other questions?
There's more questions on the
dory. Okay. You can see them now.
Yeah.
So when a collaborative scrappy,
we're culture teams and individuals
are pulled in many directions,
do you have tips for managing a wide
range of requests and opportunities from
multiple unique sources? Well, again,
it's a little bit about knowing what
you want. If you don't, if you're not,
you can't get what you want if
you don't know what you want.
And so if you're just being buffeted
by request and you can't anchor on
something that matters to you,
I do think you need to get
advice about that without,
if you cause a kid getting pulled
in all these different directions,
that's what's going to happen.
And so you're not going to be able to
carve yourself out sort of a career and a
program, a program to progress.
So I, you know, I think it's,
um, yes, you need to have people
that can help you think about that.
That's why mentoring is so important,
right?
In a culture where this happens a lot,
mentors are really key to be able to
talk to people and get advice from them
about what makes sense here for
me and what doesn't make sense.
It makes sense for me. So I think
there's sort of anchoring and having,
knowing what you want, cause you
can't get it if you don't know it,
if you don't know it.
And I think it is one of the things.
So there's so many opportunities,
it's hard to focus on it. So,
but I think if you don't,
it's very hard to sort of push
to negotiate for the thing,
then you can't really negotiate with the
things you want just being pushed back
and forth.
Now you might want to narrow it down
to a few things and use these things to
trade off each other so
that you might want to,
it might help you get
exactly what you want.
I think there are a lot
of choices here. Um, and,
and so I think focusing
is really is really key.
MMM.
You know,
I think this sounds like a theme here.
There are sexy projects and
Grosvenor projects on every team.
How do I negotiate for the ones
that will set me up for success,
which are usually the sexy ones.
So I guess I would say, again,
knowing what you want,
but you know,
doing a little of the grunt but
do it and we call this if then,
right? So I'm willing to
do this if then I do that.
So you connect these different parts of
what you're being asked to do and that
way you really do make it a sort of a,
a negotiation.
So there is a cost for you doing
the grunt work. But if you're,
the kind of person always
says no to that grunt work,
I think it's going to be an issue.
But if you're,
the kind of person always
says yes to the grunt work,
all you do is get brunt work.
So that the issue is really to make it
a negotiation. If then if I do this,
then I want to do that.
So always connect these asks,
we talk in the book about how to turn
asks into negotiations because that's
really key. You get asked all the time
and how do you make it into a negotiation?
So one of them is if then, if
then, which builds in reciprocity,
I'm willing to do this, but then something
else. And I think that's important.
Yes.
Can you talk a little bit about some
of the basics such as anchoring,
which you talked a little bit about,
um,
whether it's you starting the negotiations
at a certain point and ratcheting
back. How big do you make
your initial asks? Right.
You know, so, um, uh,
anchoring comes from a negotiations when
you're attending to negotiate about a
single issue,
right?
So you have an idea about a bargaining
zone and we make offers and we moved back
and forth on that zone and it,
it tends to be the case.
If you have good information
about the other size, other sides,
alternatives,
it pays you to make the opening offer.
I don't think this is a
little end negotiation advice.
This is external kind of advice because
I think that there's consequences to
doing what I'm about to say it. A little
end negotiation. So let me be clear.
But when you have good information
about the other person's alternatives,
it behooves you to make an opening offer.
That's what we call a large opening on
offer because your frame the negotiations
and you anchor it in a way
that's advantageous to you.
If you don't have good information
about the other side's Batna,
you have a tendency, you have, you run
the risk of either anchoring too low,
in which case you cut off a lot of
the bargaining zone or anchoring.
So much off the charts that
people sort of walk away.
The way I like to use anchoring in
little end negotiation is anchoring with
solutions.
So you know you have this,
so you're asked to do grunt work
for example. Well do you have,
can you anchor with a solution
about what you would do?
Some of it or who else
would do it? Um, uh,
so anchoring becomes solutions to problems
because you're always trying to make
trades. I meant to tell my trade story.
So I guess I'll tell my trade story. Now,
you're always looking for making trays.
You know, in the, in all negotiations,
you never want to negotiate
about a single issue.
You always want to negotiate about more
than one issue because you want to do if
then you want to have, uh,
you want to have trades.
So here's my story about trades.
This is a story about an anthropologist
who studied the Navajo in Arizona and
she finished her fieldwork and she's
driving back to Phoenix and she passes the
Navajo women on the road.
And she asked her if she wants a ride
back into Phoenix and this woman says,
sure.
And this woman gets in the car and it's
totally silent for most of the ride,
except when they're getting
close to Phoenix. The woman,
the Navajo woman notices that in between
the two seats there's a bag and she
asks the anthropologist what's in the bag.
And the anthropologist says,
it's a bottle of wine from my husband.
And the Navajo woman says, good trade.
So it's important to think about
traits, right? Trays are important.
It's always sort of, if, then we,
I didn't really talk about that
that much in this talk, but it's,
there's a lot of it in the
book always about if then,
and so anchoring in a single ish, you
know, single offer kind of situation,
you know, those are so rare.
That's not what you're doing.
Even when you're negotiating salary,
that's not what you're doing.
There's so many other
pieces that are part of it.
So Anka was solutions because
I think it does the same thing.
It frames the negotiation in a situation
that's advantageous to you because you
sort of thought about how
you, uh, how you frame it.
Okay. So suppliers, you know, I'm not
really talking about that. Um, suppliers,
uh,
you know, how you negotiate with
suppliers for on a short timeline to,
to pull in dates due to urgent demand.
Again, I think, you know, it's,
it's an if then kind of thing will they
do with this time and in return you'll
give them something else later. Um, you
know, I think that those are, um, uh,
and,
and then the then could be how we keep
each other informed so that we know more
what's happening.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
So somebody Nigga isn't negotiating on
behalf of you and they don't negotiate
well, how would you prepare
them to negotiate? Well,
I think that's a really important issue
when you are counting on people to
negotiate for you. You want to have
the first negotiation with them.
What is it you want them to do? And
sometimes I actually might need some help.
Um, uh, when they have to
negotiate on your behalf,
there may be a consequence to negotiate
on their behalf that they don't want to
pick up. And so I think you have
to find ways to sort of help them,
help them do that. Um, uh, uh,
help them figure out exactly how they
wouldn't go shake it off and negotiate on
your behalf. Um, that, that you don't,
if you may not have all the information
that they have about options and
policies, what you want to get,
ask them for that information.
So this negotiation with your manager,
it's actually the first negotiation.
It's not something that you're
just sort of talking to them.
It is negotiating to get them to buy in,
to be your advocate.
And that's what you're
sort of asking them to do.
I Dunno. Sales teams, I don't have a,
that's an open ended question that I don't
actually have a lot of advice for. Um,
I would suggest you talk to other people
on your sales team to get advice for
that.
Um,
okay.
That's it. I, um, I got some,
I interviewed some
people before I, um, uh,
came here to get some other information.
And some of the things
I learned was the case.
Scarce resource at Google is time.
So one of the major things that you're
negotiating about is really time.
And so it's, it's, uh,
trying to think about creative ways
and creative ways to negotiate,
to negotiate about time.
And so we have some ideas in
the book about that as well. Um,
especially in terms of negotiating
about work and personal life, uh,
work and personal life issues.
So are there any other questions?
Well, thank you. It's
been a real pleasure.
I hope you liked the book and you use
it. Um, and if you do have questions,
Kathy has ways to get in touch with me,
I'd be happy to sort of answer them,
answer them online.
I think there's sort of a theme here
about the kind of questions you're
overwhelmed with choices and you're
having a hard time negotiating about those
kinds of choices.
And I think it really starts with
you being clear about what it is,
what it is you want. I guess the other
thing that I didn't say when I talk about,
um, I, I said, you know,
connect what's good for you to what's
good for your organization and convert an
ask into a negotiation.
The issue is,
the way you do that is it's always yes
and that's what builds in the restaurant.
Yes, I'm willing to do this
and here's what I need.
So you're always thinking about sort
of connecting it and making it a go
negotiation. People always say,
I need more help saying, no,
I don't think that's right. I think
you want to have help saying yes hand.
And when you put the and out and they
say, well, I can't do that. He said, well,
then maybe it's not going to work.
Right.
But at least you've had an
negotiation about it. Um,
so I would encourage you in
this negotiation culture to,
to think about some of these, uh,
some of us, some of these principles.
So thank you.